Speaker 1: Every Friday we take a look through
the mailbag, so to speak.
It's really more of an Internet folder, but
it still seems like we call it a mailbag.
I don't know why it doesn't make any sense.
And emails of all sorts are featured.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com
with your thoughts about the show, politics,
questions, whatever the case may be.
So many meaty and substantive emails this
week.
Let's start one email from one of our viewers
who is a neurologist making a very important
point.
Last week, you had a caller that mentioned
nurses talking about how the covid vaccine
might cause individuals to misinterpret their
symptoms.
It seems this discussion of the nurses might
be a misinterpretation of an actual report.
There is a report that there are, quote, functional
neurological disorders after the vaccine.
I am a neurologist.
Functional neurological disorder is the medical
term for what used to be called psychogenic
symptoms.
In other words, folks are reporting symptoms
that are not of medical origin after their
vaccines.
Below is a summary of the report from Medscape.
Happy to interpret, but as a brief summary,
there are a number of neurological examination
tricks that neurologists use to identify psychogenic
versus neurological weakness.
One of these is the Hoover sign mentioned
below.
Yes.
So this is a really important thing.
A lot of the time people will not understand
the difference between a symptom and an actual
physiological side effect of a medication.
And for example, you can have a headache after
a vaccine or after a medication or after working
out or whatever.
It's not that the headache isn't real, but
there may not be a physiological cause for
that.
But it doesn't make the symptom any less real.
And there's a lot of different terms that
are sometimes applied here in different disciplines.
Sometimes people talk about psychosomatic.
We don't even need to go into that.
As our viewer here is saying, we're talking
about when we say functional neurological
disorder.
If you don't know what that means, you're
like, whoa, that's how the vaccine causes
a functional neurological disorder.
As is being pointed out, that means there
is a symptom which we don't believe to actually
be caused by something going on neurologically.
And this applies in many other areas of medicine
as well.
Very important point.
And you can read more about it, if that's
interesting to you.
Next, the email comes from Cody.
Cody says, Hello, David.
I'm having trouble dealing with the fact that
some members of my family have stated they
will never get the vaccine, especially my
brother, who's a local business owner and
comes into contact with a good deal of our
community.
I've presented them with the information on
the vaccine, how it's FDA approved, how 99
percent of deaths and 97 percent of hospitalizations
are from the unvaccinated and info on MRSA
vaccines and nothing is getting through to
them.
I often get the rebuttal that it's my body,
my choice.
But when I explain it isn't just them they
are affecting.
It's everyone around them, friends, family
and our community.
They shrug it off and suggest those people
should stay at home then.
Do you have any suggestions on a different
approach to this?
I appreciate your time and enjoy your content.
Keep up the good work.
Listen, I am not pretending to have solutions
here.
Sometimes knowing someone who gets very sick
or dies is the only thing that will change
the minds of some of these people.
Even then, sometimes that won't change their
minds.
So I don't have advice, sadly, other than
advice for you, which is at a certain point
you might decide for your own sanity.
This is a personal decision that you've had
enough and you're not going to try to convince
them anymore.
But maybe you decide you can't have them in
your lives.
That's not a suggestion.
And I've not decided that with anybody.
But you might reach a point where you say
this is too much.
The stress of this is too much.
And for safety and sanity, I'm opting out
of this relationship or you might say I'm
just going to try to keep going because it's
so important to me or you might try a different
approach.
I don't know.
I wish I had an answer about what the right
way to convince these people what the most
effective way would be to convince these folks.
Next to email today is from Michael.
Michael says, hi, I watched the show from
the UK.
Most days find them entertaining and informative.
Nevertheless, I cringed.
Oh, no.
I cringe during an article when you repeatedly
said a covid number that had tripled had increased
by three hundred percent.
Tripling means an increase of two hundred
percent, just as doubling would be a one hundred
percent increase Carol.
Well, with the math and keep up the good work,
I cringed when I realized I made this mathematical
mistake.
I make every effort to be accurate and precise
with the audience.
I appreciate the correction from Michael.
And when I said the other day, covid cases
are up three hundred percent and deaths are
up 70 percent, 300 percent is a quadrupling,
whereas the 70 percent increase in deaths
is almost a doubling of apologies and always
appreciate the corrections.
Sky wrote in Sky, says David.
My in-laws are both major Trump supporters
as well as deep into conspiracies.
My husband and his mother regularly have debates
and recently had one that took an interesting
turn.
They were talking about vaccines and in his
desperation to get her to see reason, he suggested
that all the misinformation was a liberal
conspiracy to eliminate all the anti VAX conservatives
in order to win elections.
He also posed the question of how many liberals
have died due to covid and asked her to name
one she could not.
I found this strategy interesting and thought
you might as well.
Do you do we have to sink so low as to basically
trick antibacterials into getting the vaccine
at this point?
Would it be effective or lamet damaging in
the long term?
I've talked about this before.
I think that there would be I don't know if
we would call them scam's.
There would be things Joe Biden could say
and do that would make the right go and get
vaccinated.
For example, imagine if Joe Biden announced,
like, of course, he would never do it.
It would never be legal.
But imagine if Joe Biden announced.
Because of all of the things that these red
state governors are doing after October 1st,
conservatives and Republicans will no longer
be allowed to get the vaccine.
It's like it's so obviously impossible legally
and logistically it would never happen.
But the point is, I am convinced that if trumpet's
conservatives, Republicans, whoever is in
the Antibalas group, if they came to believe
that they were not going to be allowed to
get the vaccine because of their political
views, millions of them would run out and
get the vaccine.
There's no question about it.
If a theory, hypothesis, rumor started to
spread that the left doesn't want conservatives
to get vaccinated so that they die.
I think there is no doubt that if it was believed,
if it was believed, of course, if it was believed
that a ton of these right wingers would go
out and try to get vaccinated.
Now, is it damaging in the long term?
Yeah.
I mean, if if if Joe Biden did something like
that, even if it worked, I do think in the
long term it would be damaging because it
would further foment the idea that the government
is lying to you and you can't trust the government
to do anything.
And on and on and on.
So I'm not recommending it.
I don't think it would be a good long term
play, but it would sure as hell work with
some of these some of these right wingers.
So interesting that the conversation went
that way.
Spencer wrote to me, Spencer said, I am seeing
studies suggesting that teenage boys are far
more likely to suffer from myocarditis related
to the vaccine than to end up in the hospital
from covid.
Have you heard anything backing this claim
up?
I'm only able to find a few articles talking
about it.
Yeah, I read a study this morning about it.
It's not true.
In fact, there was a study that was going
to look at myocarditis in teenage boys and
it had like a sample of nine million vaccinated
teenage boys and like, none of them got it,
or at least none of them got it badly enough
to have to be hospitalized or something like
that.
No, the evidence I've seen is that the vaccine
is safer than covid at every age group, at
every age group.
Very important because there are some who
will say if you are of a certain age, it actually
makes less sense to get the vaccine.
But from what I've seen is that at every age
group, for just about every medical condition,
you are better off with the vaccine and its
possible side effects than you are getting
covid big picture, statistically speaking.
Lastly, today, this one's a doozy, guys.
This is from Jayjay.
This stuff is constantly coming into my email,
just dumping in all the time.
Here is someone who has somehow ended up believing
really incorrect things about covid and vaccination,
Jayjay says.
David, sir.
No, they didn't say sir.
How about the adults unable to get the real
vaccines?
Also, the Delta virus thing a complete lie
covid sext when and how.
No mutations right there.
The proof needed.
It's so sad that this is going on in our country.
I don't know what else to say, you know, how
about the adults unable to get the real vaccines?
I think this is some illusion to fake vaccines.
I don't know.
The Delta virus thing is a complete lie.
You know, we we sequenced the virus, we know
what percentage of cases are Delta, we saw
Mbewe peaked in July and then has come down.
At some point, if if someone is going to say
this is an apple and you're going to say it's
not an apple, it's a fake apple, it's imaginary,
at some point you can't convince them covid
sexed.
I don't know or do viruses have have sex,
I did.
I didn't think so.
Maybe they do.
I don't think it matters incoherent and unfortunately,
really, really, unfortunately, a lot of people
I don't even know what that belief is.
I don't even know what they're saying.
But I know a lot of people believe stuff like
that because they email me all the time.
We're going to have real trouble getting out
of this pandemic.
If that type of stuff remains as prevalent
as it is, we'll track whether vaccinations
go up with the latest requirements and initiatives
from Joe Biden.
We will track all of it.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Please become a member.
Really, folks, please become a member.
Sign up at join Pakman dot com.
We do this show every day, but then we do
an extra show called the Bonus Show every
day and you can get instant access to it if
you become a member at join packing dotcom.